a little too early for work but guess
what we gonna keep grinding have a good
morning Instagram let's do this today
some pretty confidential information
okay so keep it between us all right I
just found out that the company is
better than that - Zack are you filming
this
Oh because I mean you work there's so
much potential me you numbers are you
hey sir would you like to find the
meaning of life today yeah sure why not
that's a cool building doesn't it feel
good to be alive now first of all this
is not a cult
I know we've all heard the media it's
religion filming no no that No
Justin I need your help
oh you need my help thanks goes be so
much fun yeah I have so much fun down
there yeah no I've never been to Mexico
I'm actually a little excited for it uh
yeah what's following us what
what is the capital of Mexico Mexico
City
oh no wait you're right they don't mess
around
Oh double posing this is a - that's so
annoying
there's a dude I am NOT gonna tell the
secrets of your call I swear first of
all not a cult
second of all you left my sermon without
Tagum in your story that's pretty rude